edwards attention on va tout de suite
partir chez mokhtar ou jean-michel nous
attend jean michel est ce que ça va
c'est motta que ça se passe bien bokassa
se passe bien ce soit jean michel je
suis aux anges franchement c'est très
cosy aïe c'est beau c'est très cosy chez
mokhtar presque aussi bien que chez moi
avant qu'il vienne chez les traces
apparaît alors ashton et calmez vous je
suis allé au mariage de mokhtar zerhouni
en plus affamés
mon retard venez là c'est du boulot
tâche et vous alors mokhtar jeanrichard
calvet vous comme elles valent
jean-michel on va jouer avec jean luc
lemoine c'est jean luc lemoine qui va
avoir
l'avenir de mokhtar entre ses mains je
vais poser des questions à jean à chaque
fois que jean luc se trompera bien sûr
jean michel maire fera quelque chose
dans votre maison et il a l'air énervé
jean michel il a oublié ce que vous lui
avez fait attention
jean-michel voici la première question
est ce qu'on peut avoir une musique
d'angoise s'il vous plaît merci dans
l'est dans le quart d'heure merci merci
se sont pas fait chier ils ont pris la
musique de nouvelle star brown
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention jean luc voici la question
qu'elle était l'un des premiers métiers
de mokhtar mokhtar vous ne souffrez pas
s'il souffle je le massacre moi même
quelle est l un des premiers métiers de
mokhtar mécanicien pâtissier ou danseur
étoile rappelle mokhtar alors
mécanicien pâtissier danseur étoile
c'est qu'il était majeur et un temps
wade pâtissier pâtissier ou dit mokhtar
vous avez vous avez été quoi vous longez
le boulanger pâtissier de jean michel
vous pouvez nous montrer une photo vous
avez une photo de deux motards pour
prouver qu'il a il a été pâtissier
d'actes mans ben oui qu'est ce qui lie
[Applaudissements]
série quand on voit la photo osée qui
avant de partir à l'envié de manger des
gâteaux
c'est vrai mais il est bien il a fait du
sport c'est rien ça c'est faux c'est
parce qu'il a des boules magiques c'est
rien du tout
jean michel vous êtes dans la cuisine la
syrie le oui oui oui mais écoutez moi je
dois tu dis donc je vais lire à mokhtar
il a été pâtissier et bah ça tombe très
bien d'annaba temps déjà bien répondu
ayrault il a bien reposé mien parce que
moi aussi j'adore la panade
il a bien voulu vous vous calmez vous
vous calmez jean-michel d'accord prenait
jusqu'à 9 et prenez juste un affidé du
rouille des moules off est légion où les
moules of a regardé jeter le contre-jour
pas j'en sais pas trop regarder
[Applaudissements]
cascades où il est mort je sais où il
habite
calmez-vous pour la star deuxième
question c'est jean luc lemoine qui doit
répondre
combien de poule est ce que c'est
vraiment utile que je réponde pas ce
livre là là rien fait là c'était rien ça
va ça va combien de bombes ventouses
oui il a bien pour nous pour alléger la
ville a rien fait pour mériter ça va
même source le défaut serait jeté sur un
nouveau toit ce qui touche à ce qui
commence à m'énerver là on va calmer
pour mille et calmez vous attention jean
luc lemoine combien de poule
mokhtar le séducteur avait t-il ramener
chez jean-michel lors du happening
mokhtar à domicile à 0,5 près alors 35
combien de poules 35 vous l'avez dit on
va vérifier tout de suite on va vérifier
je crois que c'était dans la chambre et
me semble que ça se passe
alors il avait versé dans la chambre que
ça se passe exactement sur la chambre
vous avez dit combien 35 35
[Applaudissements]
oh là là là là combien alors les motards
c'est bien d'autres choses apparemment
jean michel da cunha poule alors avec la
ja il avait 30 points de suture et une
mauvaise réponse donc on a bien fait de
le faire bravo
bon eh oui mokhtar samba non y'a mon
bepc rien c'est du foot ok façon je dors
chez toi oui tu donnes un poisson si tu
veux dormir chez moi tu dors chez moi
attention quelle est la couleur préférée
de mokhtar d'après sa femme le rouge le
bleu ou le jeu de moutarde comme son
magnifique baignoire
le bleu le bleuet mokhtar mokhtar vous
aimez quoi vous comme couleur le bleu
non c'est le rouge alors votre femme
votre âme que j'aime beaucoup plus ma
femme que j'adore nous a dit que c'était
le rouge et bientôt jean-michel on peut
offrir là là là on peut voir ce que
c'est quoi sa couleur préférée oui parce
que vous avez peut-être pendra mur en
rouge à pleurer lui faire plaisir
c'est le rouge mais c'est le rouge
allez-y alors l'amour
bah oui va aller que m'a faite vous de
ça chez moi la dernière fois ouais bah
si la boj de ramener chez lui et chez
moi si dablemont on va lui mettre du
rouge et bat suba voilà bah voilà bah
voilà du fond rouge comme ça là c'est
parfait
directement sur le cas là exactement
mettre partout voilà et ben voila sable
c'est beaucoup mieux comme ça attention
voici une autre question qui se cachent
actuellement derrière la porte de chez
mokhtar et s'apprête à entrer des
stripteaseuses que jean-michel connais
personnellement une équipe de rugbyman
faire après à faire la troisième
mi-temps où françois françois hollande
qui lui amène des croissants si je
réponds si je réponds c'est personne ne
rentre pas oui personnes aux bons alors
j'irai de l'équipe de rugby
prosep à françois hollande qui me mène
peut-être des croissants vous avez
raison c'est plausible
françois hollande
merci aujourd'hui que ben voilà et ma
maman alors j'ai perdu jean-michel je
crois que c'est la fin de ces motards à
jean michelet on va voir si à françois
hollande derrière despres auteur du
message est pas fait tout de suite on va
on va voir on va tout de suite voir
attention
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'équipe de rugby du matin ils
sont tous à y sont touchés
[Applaudissements]
longtemps
le temps c'est noble aulas c'est bon ça
c'est la vérité
la voix
[Applaudissements]
l'eia montant moquerait regarder la
gueule de motards l'avait salué gémeaux
taille à votre femme aussi un nom avec
la perruque blonde la doxa des hommes
qui hélas est un amoureux femmes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après
ça serait pas jean-michel grandeur du
champ
[Applaudissements]
vautard tout ça c'était pour les
mauvaises nouvelles
la bonne nouvelle mon chéri tu sais
comme je t'aime mon mokhtar jeu venu à
ton mariage j'ai eu ta femme
on a eu ta femme sache le ce soir tu
dormiras à l'hôtel c'est pour moi avec
ta femme je te le dis mon bébé c'est mon
cadeau chéri non je te dis et la
peinture
c'est pour moi ta femme voulait refaire
la peinture de la part donc je te
paierai delà toute la peinture
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à la barre ce but pour le type de
rupture elle est l inverse si l'équipe
de rugby turin et merci la femme de
mokhtar que j'adore nous verser 20,6
ritalin pourrait verser les salaires